i think we've got the warning for you
because the crazy ladies of the view
there you go what you're about to see
okay the crazy ladies of the view they
chimed in on dr jill biden's comments
and look i i honestly it's it's a stupid
thing that she said nobody look i don't
think well i think she is racist in a
way right because even because these
progressives they are racist because
they've whittled everyone down to skin
color and the pandering nonsense uh but
what the reason i'm showing you the view
right now let's put the warning up again
i want people to really feel the warning
um the reason that i'm showing you this
clip is that if ted cruz who happens to
be uh
latino descent or marco rubio or donald
trump or ron desantis made a comment
like this was like collecting their
latino people but like tacos the view
and every other show for weeks would be
saying this is what they think of you
latino people they think of you as tacos
and burritos and chimichangas and
everything else but when it comes to
democrat democrats doing these things
the entire media runs cover for them
here's whoopi goldberg first lady jill
biden has apologized after making some
unfortunate analogies during a speech to
latino americans in san antonio texas
yesterday
i can't even tell you what here's what
she said you have to just look gold
helped build this organization
with the understanding that the
diversity of this community
as distinct as the bogadas of the bronx
as beautiful as the blossoms of miami
and as unique as the breakfast tacos
here in san antonio
is your strength
these two ladies and for these two
latinos in the front row are just girls
they're hurt
and they're just they're they're they're
just
i mean
bodega is what you meant to say you
think somebody might have read the
speech
beforehand and said maybe you don't want
to say it like this yeah but this is you
know i i
i won't even say what i what it is
because it's you know we all step and
poo from time to time and so this
happens but this was really
you can hear the people going what does
she say
and then that nervousness did she just
say
see what's interesting about that is
whoopi knows that it's kind of messed up
what jill did there right she knows and
we're going to show you more in just a
second where she gets into it but for
her when it comes to the democrats
saying something they just stepped in
poo right do you think again if this was
a republican that said this if this was
josh hawley or mike lee that said oh he
just stepped in poo no it would be this
he has unmasked himself he obviously is
a racist and thinks of uh latino people
as tacos now of course the fact that
there are masked people in their
audience while they sit there on mass
that's a completely separate point um
but okay whoopi she was like sort of
like kind of almost getting there and uh
well she continued yes and speaking
about anyone don't you avoid food
related yeah that is tacos whether it's
skin color well you have to use foods i
would say i said if somebody said you
bring the chicken out in people right
you know i was i
i don't i don't know who who
yeah that's kind of what you know that
it was yeah it came from
this is what it was it was a racial
stereotype that she used racial
stereotypes so i don't know who wrote
that for but and it was such an unforced
error right because if you think about
political affiliation um there is
republicans are making the argument that
there are more um hispanics that are now
registering as republican and that i i
don't know if that's true um and i don't
think it's true because right now 56
percent
of of hispanic americans identify as
democrats whereas only 26 percent of
hispanic americans identify as
republicans so remember when when
democrats do it they step in poo or it's
an unforced error would they be that
gracious
if a republican did it i think not i
also want to comment on this thing that
the whoopi said about chicken i love
fried chicken i really love fried
chicken i love watermelon these are good
things these are good things if you like
the things there's nothing racist about
it
right like i love fried chicken i can't
i don't even know how you could
associate that with racism in any way i
have watermelon in the fridge right now
you guys want some watermelon after the
show i don't associate that with
anyone's skin color when i went to whole
foods and bought a watermelon i bought
the watermelon i dumped the watermelon i
enjoy watermelon
so if you're associating like specific
foods with specific people sure there's
ethnic things there's north south okay
people eat different things like this
but if you say to somebody oh you like
fried chicken and then if there's a
racial connotation to that
first off it just you have a racial
connotation just in and of itself is not
racist if you like the thing
right if you like the thing remember the
episode of seinfeld where jerry is
dating this woman he meets her on the
phone and her name is donna chang and he
thinks he's dating a chinese woman it
turns out she's just a white girl from
long island and elaine has to explain
they're all talking about is this racist
is this racist and it's and elaine's
like you know it's not racist if you
like the things everybody likes chinese
food we've all just racialized
everything to the point of complete
stupidity